all right guys bang bang i've got matt
here what's up man what's good man
not much uh you're the bachelor uh i
don't think that you grew up wanting to
be the bachelor how the hell does that
happen
bro it's just you kind of fall into it
like my uh you're supposed to say you
were looking for love
well that's a given you know it's like
i'd never given myself a chance to
to explore what a relationship looked
like so when the opportunity uh
presented itself
it was something that i entertained
initially and then my roommate's mom
tyler
tyler's mom really pushed me she's like
you know i saw how much
this pushed tyler in the direction that
he needed to go and become a man and
uh he was already on the show he had
been on the bachelorette as a contestant
so he was pursuing the world but he
didn't win he was he didn't win
all right did you when he comes back or
you're like you're a loser you lost or
or is it just like not like everyone
except for one you know what's funny
about that he wouldn't tell me what
happened
and that's my homie that's my guy i'm
like yo so like what happened like are
you engaged he's like
i'm like he was acting weird you know
what i mean really just because i was
expecting him to come back and be like
tell you everything yeah but like it
really did change them for the better
and so i was like i took that into
consideration when i was thinking about
doing it myself
how much did that play into you getting
selected do you think like that your
roommate had been on the show versus
uh it wouldn't have mattered you know i
think it helped a lot because it gave me
visibility uh into that fan base you
know what i mean and what they were
looking for and
um i don't think that i would have been
in that
spotlight without that friendship and
relationship with tyler because
i think the peak of that was during
quarantine you know after i had gone out
to california to film the bachelorette
like i was initially supposed to be a
contestant oh interesting
yeah yeah so i was supposed to be a
contestant and
covet happened and i'm in my hotel i
don't have a phone i don't have anything
and it's like
wait they don't you don't they don't
give you any electronics anything bro
you're i'm just watching tv it's like
ncaa tournament canceled like uh fifa
canceled i'm like yo if all this stuff's
canceled how are you about to film
and then like literally clockwork
someone walks in like hey we're gonna
postpone for two weeks so
um we're gonna get you a flight back to
new york i call tyler he's like yo
don't come to new york [ __ ] in the fan
like come down to jupiter
so i'm like done i came from jupiter
because
his mom had passed away and i was down
there for the funeral so i stayed
another week and then flew out to
california so i just came right back to
jupiter
and um hannah who was on who was the
bachelorette that he was pursuing
um during his season was in florida as
well
for the funeral so she came back down
and we were all kind of quarantining
together
and then that snowballed into this
opportunity where
um i was presented the opportunity to be
the bachelor when you get that phone
call or email do you like jump up and
down
you're like let's [ __ ] go or is it
like a damn am i really gonna do it like
do you like are you worried about saying
yes or
is it like a celebratory thing you know
it's funny so like at that time
at the in the house that i was
quarantining in like it was the peak of
prank wars like there's
like we like we were at each other's
necks there's 10 people living in like a
two-bedroom house
and so i i thought it was a joke like i
thought someone was messing with me
because it's a it's an area code i've
never seen yep it's someone i had never
spoken to so i get this call
i'm just like who paid this person i'm
just like on
edge and then they called back the next
day and i was like oh [ __ ] this is real
and um i was honored you know because i
know the type of
the type of research and the type of um
i just know how difficult it is to to be
in that pool of people that they're
considering and what an honor it would
be to be the first black person to do
that
so um yeah it was surreal it was surreal
all right so you get there
uh you meet all these girls what's going
through your head like that like to me
it's just like
there's this element of uh um wow all
these girls are here for me
right so like there's probably like a
i'm the man right at the same time like
oh but it's gonna be on national
television
like throws a wrench in things like
i'm have to be careful as to like what i
say do whatever because everything's
filmed right right
uh and then you like get into it and is
it literally
as emotional and for for those that are
listening uh i've never watched this
show before but i saw matt beforehand
um my wife is a a 20 year veteran i
think of the show
and uh so i started watching uh because
we've got some friends that
are mutual friends and it's like sports
man
like literally like you could cheer on
one girl over another girl or whatever
right and you're like
you you get into it and it's like is
that the same thing for you on the other
side of it
you know it's different for me you know
because these are real relationships i'm
dealing with
are they real come on are they really
they're real for me and i think that's
why
uh that's why it worked for me because
when like to your point there's people
who have bachelor pools and they're
doing all this stuff like oh we wonder
and and that's fun and it gets people
engaged but for it to work and for it to
be real and
for those connections to be valid you've
got to be vulnerable and
that's not something that i was ever
comfortable with being or doing
just because like i was conditioned as a
man just to keep all that stuff inside
and not share like our friend my friend
group didn't talk about stuff like that
and so when i'm like forced to address
these things that i've never talked
about or
come to terms with with these women you
just form
this connection and bond over sharing
things with people you've never shared
before
and also being disconnected from work
email
phone like you don't have any
electronics like it's just you and these
women out there
trying to figure out if you're
compatible with one another so it's
weird if like a friend called me up and
started saying all kinds of emotional
stuff you'd almost be like
you good right well now now i'm like yo
i welcome those conversations yeah yeah
it's funny after the experience like uh
you find yourself just like
trying to have these like deep
conversations so it's like if you
a common question you get is so how are
you feeling pom
like i feel good like if you ask me how
i'm feeling
man let me tell you like it's been a
tough day like i've had this going on
and i think you're more honest yeah you
just
you just dive deeper and you look to
have those type of connections and
conversations
so after the show i'm like having these
conversations with people and they're
just like yo like are you good
you're just like no i just want to know
like it's because it feels good to get
those things off your chest and share
yeah
uh the host what's his name chris chris
all right what's he like behind the
scenes
he was great you know i uh i spent a lot
of time with chris because
um during the days that we weren't
filming we would
uh we'd catch up catch up on
how i'm feeling there was times where he
had his family there
and a lot of the producers would have
their family there and it just made it
real because you know there's the work
and then like when the cameras are off
it's like oh this guy's a dad like oh
this guy
like what's he doing though is he like
smoking a cigar drinking a drink
chilling with his kids
he's doing prep work yeah his kids are
in high school so he's doing helping
them out at the house and
he's he's an avid golfer so he's playing
a lot of golf um so he's on vacation
basically well you know
it might seem like that to somebody but
like to him he's working because when he
comes on set he's ready to go
yeah he was yeah and how many people you
said there's like a couple hundred
people there as part of this production
pom there was so many people there like
producers
lighting sound um uh
you have the the staff of nemacon you've
got
it it's such a it's such a big vehicle
and you don't really have i didn't have
any concept of that until i got there
and i'm just like wow yeah i had no idea
there was so much that went into
making this work for everybody so when
i'm watching the show a couple times you
pulled up in nice cars you had nice
clothes i was like damn this guy's
killing life i was like what do they
bring you in a garage and they're like
what car you want to drive up in this
scene or like how does that work
it's funny about that so the g wagon
was actually maggie's and maggie uh owns
who's maggie maggie's the ceo of 84
lumber because she also
owns nemacon the resort got it and so
miss hardy
maggie hardy she would uh she let me use
her car for some of the stuff
nice and um and they own all those cars
on property they have a
uh i would say a car museum on property
okay
rolls bentley porsche so i was driving
the porch i didn't know how to drive
stick so i had to learn how to drive
stick before i got there
so i'm in jupiter like a week before
filming like in my buddy james mcgrath's
jeep like stalling out in the middle of
the street like i'm like
i'm screwed like i'm not gonna get it
working fast forward to
the first night i had to drive
maybe a hundred yards that's it like all
right matt like just pull up
bro i couldn't get the like i couldn't
how many takes did it take it took like
10 minutes they're like
they're like they're like forget it
we're gonna push them up they were gonna
push me
they had production people behind the
car ready to push me into the frame
and then run out and i was gonna act
like i was driving out all right there's
no way we're doing that like i'm gonna
get this thing going then like last try
like i finally got it in gear
and i'm like speeding in but uh yeah and
i learned how to drive stick in it so
all right and then close those uh they
got like a whole like wardrobe and like
a whole team that's like there to make
you
you know look fashionable or what they
got a whole they got a whole team
and um that's what i need yeah i need it
too like obviously i uh
i'm not the most fashion for person and
i'm all about comfortability so like
uh if they weren't having me get into
these clothes then i'd be wearing sweats
and i don't think that that's
the proper attack well it may have made
the show even more entertaining right
they're like oh this guy refuses to wear
the tuxedo
he's just wearing sweatshirt sweatsuit
rose ceremony like a velour jumpsuit
like that would be my vibe
it's like something super comfy how
scripted is it
uh i wouldn't say a scripted law i think
that
i think that people would be surprised
at how
how interesting and how wild reality is
opposed to
making up or trying to compile things
that
people think would be a good show so
like as things play out in real time
that's crazier than anyone could imagine
doing and like
scripting so there wasn't a lot that had
to be added into the mix for it to be
drama and things that were taking place
and there's a lot of drama
i didn't realize how much drama goes
into this stuff uh
how much of like the actual show that
gets aired
is that like on a percentage basis is
that like five percent of everything
that happened is that
eighty percent of stuff that happens
like just how i guess compressed do they
actually have to make the experience so
they can fit in tv
well it's a great question pom it's like
you're out there filming for like almost
two and a half months so it's like
oh yeah every if you asked every single
woman who was out there
they're gonna wish that they had oh they
should have put this in and they're
gonna ask me
like there's like good luck to whoever's
job that is to make
a cohesive story include everything that
everyone wants in there
because you have hours days weeks of
footage to go through so
i think they do a really good job of
just making it work with
all the footage they have and trying to
tell that story that is going to
resonate with people
how far into the two and a half months
were you like yo i know who it is like
like i know who the winner's gonna be oh
man
um and don't say two and a half months
um it's funny like you have you have
your eye on a few like that first night
where you just like
it's like you have this connection and
you're like i need to make sure that
this feeling is real and it's it's
validated over the course of one-on-one
dates and these group dates that you're
having so like
i would say that
i would say i knew i had an idea really
yeah really idea pretty early
but then it's hard because they have do
you add people to the mix i say then it
feels like they just like they're
throwing uh
kind of curveballs at you throughout the
entire show right they had a bunch of
other girls show up
then they had somebody who just came in
i think like a night and like as this is
all happening
are you finding out like at the same
time that everyone else on the show is
finding out
yeah it's it's they're not like yo matt
tomorrow like curveball no idea
and and i think that's what makes it
exciting for everybody and that's where
you get the realist
raw reaction out of myself you know
because if i knew that someone's coming
then i could be like
whoa like you know it's like i didn't
want any of that and
i don't think they wanted that for me
either so uh whenever people would pull
up like
did you know the girls that were gonna
be on the show before you actually
started filming i had no idea oh really
yeah no because uh by the time i got
into
the property like my phone was gone my
laptop i didn't have any connection to
the outside world so when that
information is being released just take
it from you there's like now you can't
have this
pretty much they're like it's funny
because like you think that they forget
it's like all right we're gonna get your
phone a few weeks it's like
whatever like they're not gonna come for
it and then it's
like it's clockwork all right like give
it up and then really yeah they just
take everything
but i mean i say that and i think it's
good because
if if you had a line to the outside
world then it wouldn't be the same
experience
yeah are you able to talk to like
friends or family or it's like like uh
it sounds crazy but like in jail yeah
you don't have a phone but like there is
a phone that there's a line
that's right and maybe you only can use
it for 20 minutes a day but like you can
communicate with people outside
is there some equivalent of that here
you know what's funny so
you're like yes that's exactly what it's
like
and they made me pay to use it bro you
after a while it's it's all it's
honestly liberating not having your
phone yeah because
we're tied to it so like outside of like
wondering how like my family and friends
are doing
um unless there's like some major
event or accident and i didn't really
want to be on my phone or be
communicating with anybody because i
liked
how like i think in normal life every
five or ten maybe even every two or
three minutes we're checking our phone
like if you were to get you ever looked
at how many times uh there's a thing on
an iphone
how many times you pick it up or the
screen lights up no there's somewhere to
look at that
yeah it's bad i looked once i actually
i'm gonna say this and people are gonna
freak out i think like one time i looked
it was like 700 times a day they're
lying
i swear and because like notifications
right so then i started shutting
notifications off
whatever but like if you just sit there
for an hour right and you think how many
times you pick up your phone
it's like four or five times more than
you think you really did a lot right
yeah you're like
i pick up my phone once an hour exactly
but that's how it was when i got back so
like when i got my phone back
i wasn't used to like having to text
people and call
so i was just and then you kind of get
worked back into
just checking it constantly which i
don't like but you know
what do you check when you wake up like
what's the first app that's a great
question the first thing i check is
twitter matt this is a theme here i only
ask good questions
i would say the first thing i check is
twitter because that's where i go for my
news
okay so i'll check i'll see what's
trending and then i'll see
there's a bunch of hashtags that i
follow uh some stuff in crypto some
stuff in sports
and then politically uh and then i'm
caught up so i check everything to make
sure that i'm not like
because there was a time where i was
traveling once and i was off the grid
for like four hours and i put out a
tweet
and it wasn't insensitive but it was
based off of what where the country was
at that time people were like yo
do you live in a in a hole and i was
like oh because you you didn't write
something i didn't know what was going
on
i had no idea like read the room exactly
exactly it's not what you said it was
just more of like hey
uh it's kind of like a brand right they
got scheduled tweet all sudden something
bad happens
and then they're like hey go buy peanuts
you couldn't be more spot on that's how
it was and so now i'm in a habit of like
okay before i do anything like let me
see where we're at
like oh okay i'm gonna stay off social
media is that crazy though that that's
the world we live in where like
literally we wake up in the morning and
we're like all right where are we in the
spectrum of you know today right are we
in like where everyone's outraged about
something there's some like catastrophic
event that happened we're like no we're
good okay fine i can go live my life
right i think that i think it ebbs and
flows like i think that it's a cycle
that we're in
and it's something that we talked about
uh before we got on is
is there's going to be a point where the
people canceling everybody are the ones
that are getting canceled and i think
until that happens like we're going to
be in this space where everyone's kind
of walking on eggshells
and in some instances rightfully so
because there's things that people have
been getting passes on for far too long
but then there's other instances where
it's like okay we need to
give people a space to have
conversations and not be critical about
them
and i think that we're going to find
that balance as we continue to ebb and
flow
is it unfair that like social media
stuff almost requires or like is
demanding everyone be perfect like
is it better if we just hey look humans
aren't perfect like everyone has
mistakes they say stupid [ __ ] we're all
actually pretty dumb compared to like
you know like computers or whatever and
so like let's just admit that we're all
flawed and then like let's work to get
better together rather than say like no
the expectation or default is perfection
and if you're not there then like
you literally get cancelled i mean
i think that what i try to do is remind
the people who follow me and the people
that i interact with is that i am
all those things i'm not a perfect
person i'm continually gonna i'm
continually gonna make mistakes
and if they're if they're coming to me
for xyz
just to give that disclaimer that you
know like um
as much as i try to be the model citizen
like there's things that i will do and
say that constantly make me fall short
so like
just have grace on me and i'm gonna have
grace on y'all uh
but but that is the expectation that is
so important right it's like if you go
into it knowing like hey man you're
gonna make mistakes i'm gonna make
mistakes
and then you make the mistake like well
yeah i told you i was gonna make
mistakes right
right right rather than i think a lot of
people especially as they get bigger
audiences like i'm perfect
right right like oh i got the perfect
instagram photo every tweet has been
passed through seven pr filters right
right right then you're like wait a
minute like you cheated on your wife
like
yeah hey you were supposed to be up here
right yeah and you start to like i mean
look we just talked about bill gates is
probably the best example like there was
this whole
you know hey i'm a philanthropic you
know person i got this whatever
and you find out you're like well hold
on a second those are actually
in many cases uh they're not great yeah
but that story is as old as time in
terms of people
you know just doing dumb stuff yeah but
it's almost like the the bigger they are
the more we put them on a pedestal the
harder they can fall
i think you bring up an interesting
point pom and that's that the more
authentic and organic you are
on your social platforms the more
and not maybe not grace but the more
open to
those things type of understanding
understanding exactly because if you're
if you're if you're posting imperfect
pictures of yourself like oh yo this guy
is just as ugly as i am it's like oh
this guy has like nose hairs
it's just like things that you wouldn't
think that someone in the limelight
would want to post about themselves
like the more relatable you are the more
people are going to have
an understanding of where you're coming
from opposed to being this like angel
and then like that fall is going to be
hard because it's like i knew they
weren't perfect
yeah was also i think there's a there's
this element of like the more people
preach about like ethics
and um honesty and integrity and like
all these things that like everyone
covets and we think our really important
skills or
um kind of values right if somebody's
out there every day just pounding the
table
i've learned over time like they're
doing some sketchy [ __ ] right right
right i don't know when the shoe drops
in six months or literally 10 years
but at some point that person is going
to be exposed 100
it's just because there is the
projection right it's the belief that
like oh
uh i'm not this person so if i project
to be that person then everyone i fooled
them
yeah right and it feels like that's
actually like the bad part of it yeah
and i see a lot of that and i try to be
cognizant of that as i'm dealing with
friends
people close to me who are going through
stuff like that because i know that
you're one bad decision away from being
bro you have a hat on says bandit like
like no one can think that you're
perfect you know i love this ad i won't
take it off
all right uh so as you guys are
finishing the show uh you finally let
everybody else know what you've known
for a little bit right
is uh is rachel's gonna be the uh the
winner right um
is she happy about that like did she
want to win uh by the way we're having
this conversation she's in the room
rachel shout out just i'll get some
answers for you guys rachel i
um i've never done an interview with her
right here before so this would be
interesting
uh oh even better all right perfect
um i think she was excited you know i
was definitely excited
because we've had uh i'm sorry i'm just
laughing at the fact that you're like i
think she was excited
like because can you feel the heat of
her just staring at us all right
i'm gonna burn right we'll get that over
go ahead
um because we there's so much of our
relationship that we want to celebrate
and share with everybody
and we've had to hide and be in hiding
because we don't want to ruin
uh this experience as it's errand for
everybody else so we're
again walking on eggshells so that we're
not giving things away but i'm
constantly doing bonehead stuff to like
give it away like i was listening to one
of her playlists on spotify
and people figured it out did people
figure out everything hold on
all right so listen to the context the
show ends right uh you've picked rachel
rachel's the winner
um you guys like get released to the
wild
essentially right like back into society
right uh and you're told in november
uh you said that nobody can see you it
together until
march right okay what happens
for four or five months right you're so
excited all this stuff what do you do
for five months
well i'll listen to her playlist on
spotify
that's a you know that's like the old
cds remember like in middle school
girl would like write on it and give you
the cd if you really like somebody you
would burn a cd for him yeah yeah
exactly i had a playlist for him
uh but i think me and rachel's
relationship was a little bit different
because a lot of things happen you know
like
um we would uh from a standpoint of like
what we did together like we couldn't
leave the house so like you're limited
to
we watched a bunch of movies uh we
worked that way through disney plus like
rachel's
the biggest marvel fan there is so like
she's giving me
uh like a high level graduate education
on
the history of all these different
characters and i'm trying to catch it
it's basically like bachelor for kids
you know to some degree right like
different players guys
yeah no it was that was a lot of fun
though we we we got to do things like
that that
you know if we had the opportunity to do
things outdoors we probably probably
wouldn't spend as much time doing and
then we there was like rough patches on
our relationship you know like we
uh we actually uh broke up for a moment
while the show was airing and then after
the show
aired um and the finale happened um
we found ourselves back to well we're
back together now
when you break up is that like uh
what a normal person would think of as a
breakup or now that
everyone in the world watches is it like
something different like going back to
like is it like you're still a human
right right
is she i think yeah like when you guys
like have a good or bad times like it's
the same thing in any relationship that
you had before the show
right all right uh when you guys get
back together
is that like a 2 a.m you up text that
like a normal person would send
when they're drunk or is that like a hey
you know uh we saw each other somewhere
for an event like how does that happen
uh well i think that's an interesting
question because
there was if you tell me you up text
right now i'm gonna die
definitely not a you up text uh it was
it was it was honestly
um a commitment that we had made to each
other that we were gonna work on the
relationship
and there became there came a point in
time where
uh it was evident that my working on the
relationship looked different than
rachel's because
um i wasn't really honoring that um
commitment that i made to working on our
relationship
and uh it was just a come to jesus
meeting that i had with rachel where
she's like if you're gonna make this
work then like let's do it but if you're
not gonna make make
it work then like then i'm gonna let you
do your own thing
and um that's really all i need is that
ultimatum
it was it was it was an ultimatum that i
needed because i was yeah it was
appreciated but it was uh yeah
let me put my foot down exactly but it's
uh my wife's in the room too she does
that all the time
but like not over like hey the
relationship like you better take the
trash out or
you know yeah no no no it was it was
what i needed and it and it's um
it's been great what's up guys before we
continue with this interview
i want to quickly talk about our sponsor
kraken kraken is one of the most
established and secure places to buy
cryptocurrencies on the internet
they've been at the forefront of the
bitcoin and blockchain revolution
for over 10 years their mission is to
bring crypto to the masses so whether
you're an og
or this is your first trade kraken has
all of the tools that you need to
achieve financial freedom
with more than 60 cryptocurrencies
available you can invest in
all of the most popular projects in the
industry including bitcoin
ethereum and many many more kraken also
provides in-depth articles
and guides on every single asset that
they list so you can get up to speed
quickly
and make smarter investment decisions
visit kraken.com
bang bang to get started today again
that's kraken.com
bang bang all right let's get back into
this interview i hope you're enjoying it
all right uh best thing about her and
most annoying thing about her oh
that is she she's not listening don't
worry
put your headphones in um the best she
looked really excited when i asked that
question like that was exactly what she
came for
right oh no that's funny um
we got to answer still yeah no
it's hot in here um no i would say the
best thing about rachel is
is her heart you know she's she's the
most kind caring person
understanding i've ever met you know
everything we've been through
everything she's been through she's
stuck right by my side and
she's continued to have a positive
attitude towards everything and
um it's one of the many things i love
about her but
um i have a list of things that i don't
like about
not that you don't like just the most
annoying thing she does the most
annoying thing
um that thing the thing you just thought
of right there what was that thing
um the most annoying thing oh i got it
so
um oh that was a good one whatever that
was that was a breakthrough moment so
i'm
i'm really particular about the laundry
okay
and in what way and like i don't like to
dry my stuff because
it fits me a certain way because like i
have long pants and shirts that i want
to fit i don't want my
i thought you were going to tell me that
you only wear dirty clothes or something
no i don't like like i like to air dry a
lot of stuff so like
i did my laundry separate from rachel
and then rachel did her laundry
and she puts her laundry in my laundry
okay like not a big deal
um like in the washer or in the dryer
and the dryer and um
so like that's violating the air dry
because now we're going in the dryer
but but it's not just that it's that she
she continued to dry the clothes for
three days
so like now the clothes have been drying
for the past week
and i'm like yo rachel like are you
planning on folding same clothes same
clothes yeah i'm like i'm gonna have to
donate my shirts to stuart little
because
none of my stuff fits anymore like i
don't i'm gonna have to make these pants
capris like for the longest time i
thought the dryer was just a replacement
for the iron right like if you got a
wrinkled
shirt you just put a little water on it
throw it in the dryer that's how that's
how rachel utilizes it you know she'll
put it on like fluff mode
and i didn't i didn't even know that was
a thing i just thought you you dry
clothes in there but uh
you know it's it's uh it's not that it's
not that deep but i like to give a hard
time about it because uh
if that's the biggest uh thing that
annoys you then you're doing all right
yeah
yeah i would say all right uh what's the
spotify playlist
what what happened here so i thought it
was a private playlist
okay but it wasn't it was a public
playlist when
i think when you're on the computer if
you're on spotify on the computer you
could see if you're following me on
spotify whose playlist i'm listening to
so i was listening creepy [ __ ] bro you i
mean a bachelor nation's it's only
yes and you've got a decent like private
investigators
right right but like another thing pomp
is like like i'll post like
parts of a song and like a workout i'm
doing or at the beach or eating and
people are like yo what's your song so
like people are constantly going to your
so you got a decent amount of people
following you on these these social
channels
so it wouldn't be out of the ordinary
for them to be online be like oh what's
matt listening to
wait wait no
you know it's like he's listening to
rachel's like he's giving it away so
it's like
by like on accident you get a call from
the producers they're like yo get the
hell off spotify you know what
i get you you start getting dms like um
like uh
some are nice and some are like hey just
a heads up like you should probably get
off
yeah oh good looks like like appreciate
it and then and then you like
you try to double down so you try to
find someone else who has a playlist and
you're like you know i'm also listening
to her playlist i'm listening to his
playlist
it's like wait you shot it you gotta
throw people off a little bit
but um it was it was no secret did you
ever think you'd spend your life trying
to figure out what playlist to listen to
to throw off
throw off people hey this past six
months i've i've spent a lot of time
doing things that i never thought i'd
end up doing
what's the craziest thing you guys did
to uh
hide the fact that you guys were
together during those like five six
months when
you weren't allowed to be seen together
um i think the craziest thing would be
uh the outfit changes all right what
does that mean so like whenever
like if if rachel and i were together
and
we wanted to go to a trader joe's or we
wanted to go
to um what's that pasta place that i
like
in um california
john and vinnie's i love john and
vinnie's their pasta's fire so
she do that real quick well you knew it
so i'm like if we were gonna do
something like that
it's like hoodie
hat glasses like tied up so you can only
see like
the shades and the hat matt how tall are
you i know bro i'm
not hiding from anybody i forget how
tall i am
and it's like you can't hide six five
you know what i mean it's like
all right so that so you got to change
your outfit what does she change your
outfit too
she does yeah she does the outfit swaps
because she go to the dryer to get the
clothes
i mean that's where she keeps your
clothes there right she you know what
she
she is uh very clean and um
every time we're together it's it's it's
either constantly cleaning the kitchen
because we're making
a mess or it's constantly doing laundry
because we're doing activities so
um i wouldn't be surprised if it was
multiple trips i i heard uh
recently i didn't hear uh my wife sent
it to me which was probably a negative
thing
uh and it was a meme on the internet and
it was like i'm moving out of my house
as a woman post and said i'm moving out
of my house at three years my husband
just hit me with
i liked this place the dish soap was
always full
like he's completely oblivious to the
fact that it was getting replaced
right right right yeah so i feel like
there is an element of you know you just
gotta kind of
be cognizant of what's going on i try to
be i try to be
um i try my best all right so outfit
changes is literally the craziest thing
you guys have ever done
um i think that i think the outfit
changes and then like once
like once after the show aired um
like we were technically together but
like
we didn't we wanted to live our life
outside of the
the media and cameras and all that stuff
so like
um
we went to dinner like in the cut like
deep in brooklyn
and um i wanted to get ice cream after
the fact
and um she didn't want to walk around no
she didn't care
i'm like uh i'm like y'all kind of want
to go get ice cream she's like all right
she's like do you want to walk over
there because she knows that people are
going to see us i'm like yeah
oh my god it doesn't bother me and then
we get outside i'm like
um you want to put my hoodie on like
trying to give her like a like a outfit
to like disguise she's like no like i'm
not putting your hoodie on like we're
going to doing this i'm like all right
fine whatever
so like just coming back to grips with
the fact that like
we don't have to do that stuff anymore
it's great like we don't have to hide
being together and doing activities
together it just makes living life
together easier
is there like paparazzi and like that
type of stuff or is it mostly just like
fans
i saw you listen you don't know that i
saw this but uh you're with my boys up
in new york with uh
seth and ben captain and you and you
guys were going down the street like you
know gang gang
literally in scooters i don't know what
y'all you guys are all on different
mechanical devices
flying down the street oh my gosh yo
seth
ben wilton those guys are out of control
like i love kicking it with those guys i
met them down here in miami ben's the
one that i know the best
i don't really know the other guys that
well but ben like when he uh i don't
know who posted or whatever i saw
i was like what are all these dudes
hanging out together doing it's funny
because
ben has uh like people give me a hard
time about
my means of transportation because i
have a one wheel that i love to ride and
then i have a super 73 that i'm ripping
all over the place
um bin is the same way with scooters and
everyone in our crew had like some sort
of like
like electronic vehicle that you would
use like when you're in like 56th grade
so it's like
we're like these big humans just like
mobbing down sixth avenue like
on like one wheels and scooters i
literally saw the video it sort of put
music to it yeah
it was like as you guys were going with
someone kind of got up i headed into the
side right was filming it
it's like it's kind of like the avengers
bro i wish man
no i wish i wish it was like avengers i
uh but no that's that's how we like
that's one of the things i miss about
new york you know i'm down here in miami
but um
i miss the connectivity that i had up
there and being able to
bounce from one place to another pretty
seamlessly everything's like right there
yeah what are you gonna do now like what
do you wanna do kind of moving forward
you got this massive audience
everyone knows who you are uh you've got
rachel uh i think that she likes you
that seems like she likes you
some days uh some days yeah well only
when you don't complain about the
laundry
what do you want to do now um i just
want to be a part of meaningful projects
you know i uh
i fell in love with hydroponic farming
over quarantine
uh someone let us grow sent us a farm
stand and i'm like
yo our plants are gonna die there's no
way we can do this ourselves
and when the plants that we planted in
this farm stand
that tyler and i were like watching and
feeding and and
um giving water to sprouted
into these massive kale heads and
strawberries uh
these baby tomatoes and straw like i was
i'm like yo if we can do this
literally anybody can so i'm like how
can we get this
in these urban areas that we work with
in new york city and across the country
so like that's something i've been
working on
is um the scalability of the hydroponic
space
and every time i say hydroponics people
are like weed hydroponics
i'm like well you can grow anything in
there i'm talking about growing food so
um for now just kidding kidding kidding
kitty kitty
all right so you want to do that uh and
then crypto
all of a sudden i saw you started
tweeting about bitcoin and stuff and we
got introduced yeah
uh where what's so fascinating about
that so i think that the intro to crypto
was through
um my fascination with the nft space and
how i saw people all across the world
were
being awarded this opportunity to
advance
not only their professional degree their
professional careers but
um just economics like i could invest
in an artist and uganda i can invest in
artists in taiwan who wouldn't have that
visibility without
this platform without
the connectivity and and the
what everything that everything that
you're allowed to utilize through an nft
and the stories that you can tell
and um through that research i
i you know bitcoin and all these
they've always been buzz words and i
didn't really know a lot about it and um
when i tweeted something about nft and
one of my buddies reached out to me john
marbach and he's like if uh it was like
it was like
it was like morpheus reaching out to nia
he's like he's like if you want to learn
more
like meet me at my apartment at eight
o'clock i was like oh
[ __ ] like i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm in like
i'm getting violent so
he invites me to his apartment pomp the
secret society has accepted you
it was hilarious like i get there um and
john's like
one of the smart like one of the smarter
people i know went to college together
um has a place in new york get to his
apartment and he just starts
unloading about how like what his
involvement in the space is and
um the different opportunities that are
there and i'm coming at him hard with
these he's just like the opposition like
well what about this what about that and
he's just like
if you read this if you read that he had
a he had an uh answer for every question
i had
and i did my own research shout out john
yeah john was bro that's the thing i
like about the crypto community though
it's like
people want to educate you on and like
not with misinformation but just like
they want you to understand where
they're coming from and they
uh not only understand but offer any
advice and
i can't say that for other investment
vehicles financial institutions that
i've participated in the past that
people are so willing to give
information the other ones don't want
you to exactly
make money exactly that's how they make
money so it's like uh
it and just from an economic standpoint
like someone who studied economics it
just made sense
there's a fixed supply the demand is
going to go up so the price
has to follow and you know we're in a
volatile time right now there's probably
going to be more
but like the fundamentals of why i
invested haven't changed
and what i'm using it as hasn't changed
and
uh as long as those things contin
continue to stay
finite then i'm going to continue to put
money into it so i think it's smart you
got laser eyes on twitter now i gotta
raise your eyes
all right when you did that what did
bachelor nation say about laser eyes
they were like yo
oh my gosh it's funny because like that
was like
like there's no there is literally
nothing that is similar from like
driving a porsche looking fly going to
be
20 girls that are competing for you and
then putting laser eyes
and being like by the dip like those two
worlds are completely different
i'm like and mind you at this time like
the the the mat that people
came to know on the show like clean
shaven like i have
i haven't shaved since the show look
like nipsy hustle a little bit i
appreciate that
right that's pretty good yeah no i uh i
get that a decent amount really yeah i
get that
i feel like i'm smart though i just need
to i need the cornrows but um
but so like like the pictures that are
coming like they're not hearing from me
because i'm not on the show anymore but
like there's like matte spot it's like a
yeti it's like there's like dude has a
beard and he's like
leaving walmart it's like like who is
this guy and then um
and then so when you leave i'm gonna
take a picture and be like i spotted man
exactly
oh god here we go the media storm around
that
but um so they're seeing that and then
like the next thing i post is like
like a picture of me in a tuxedo with
laser eyes so like all right this guy's
literally lost his mind like what
is he is he possessed by a demon like
what does this eat
and so but it's cool because it starts a
conversation it's like you know like
to my laser focus to the moon oh what's
that so it just it sparks conversation
that i want to have around something
that i'm interested in
and i'm inviting um pushback on so that
i can
um further validify or solidify
uh why i feel have these strong
convictions about
um this investment and uh just the
community in general
so the most interesting thing to me is
as you
kind of uh evolve your interests you
learn more about crypto you learn more
about hydroponics whatever
the audience that you have is literally
180 degree difference than mine right
mine is like if you look i'm like
youtube is like 95 male right
at one time saw that she was like oh we
gotta get some more females
like listen it's just like the type of
the content really attracts a certain
type of person
right uh but you have like 90 95 percent
women right because of the show and all
this stuff and so
do you feel like uh there's an
opportunity to kind of expose
a different audience to different ideas
right regardless of what the ideas are
what the exact
audience is it feels almost like your
interests are
very different than what they normally
would kind of consume right i'm assuming
most of your audience doesn't have laser
eyes
right almost 100 of my audience has
laser eyes right so it's just like
such a different uh kind of you know
circle of people
that you're really introducing a lot of
these new ideas to yeah i think that i
think that when
you're in a position of influence that
you have a responsibility
and um i'm i'm not
the chair of the fed i'm not controlling
that's a good thing
that's a job that no one can win you
know what i mean like i i have very
little say on
on anything outside of my own opinions
and when i find something that i think
is going to be
something that's going to be here for a
while and something that i want to pass
on to the students and the families of
the students that i work with
then i think that it's a responsibility
to at least make people aware of
um tools that are out there that they
could
change the trajectory of their life and
especially with cryptocurrency
i think that we've seen um historically
uh communities that have been
marginalized and discriminated against
um can't get loans they can't buy houses
they can't buy cars and like
those barriers to entry don't exist the
way they do
with traditional financial institutions
the way they do with crypto and that was
something that was
intriguing to me because if the families
that i work with
and the kids that we work with have
access to these tools now
and something that i only think is going
to gain momentum
um public um onboarding and
institutional onboarding going forward
then like it would be an honor for me to
be the person that bridges the gap
between them
and replicate that uh for women who are
following me you know there's no reason
why they shouldn't be
a part of this conversation as well it's
it's conversations that rachel and i
have on a regular basis you know
she's constantly challenging my um
thoughts and views on um being a bitcoin
maximalist and
all other things crypto so that rachel
no [ __ ] coins all right
and i like it because it helps me come
to a better conclusion of
of what like what my truths are rooted
in and it helps her understand like oh
like that makes sense
because everything you're saying should
make sense like it's not a secret
there's no like
theorem or it's the intellectual almost
like combat or battle of ideas right
where you come in you're like i got this
idea she asks you questions you're
almost in some way educating but at the
same time you're getting a gut check on
you know do i actually know what i'm
talking about do you really believe this
exactly
yeah uh polina thinks that satoshi's a
female
that is a popular take and i
i think that i don't think that she's
wrong on that really i've heard that
before
and i why do you think that i'll tell
you why she thinks it
i think it because of the rationale that
that went into the protocol and i don't
think it's something that
would have been i think that
i think that men are more greedy and i
think that there would have been some
sort of way to maybe
um hoard the potential i don't know i
just think that it's too fluid of a
system for it to be created by one of us
so planet thinks it could be a female
because
uh men are too egotistical right see
like somebody
ought to be like yo i made that [ __ ]
that's me yeah i like that
i like that that's so true but she's
like no actually
it takes a special type of person right
which from a
probability standpoint is more likely a
woman than a man i don't know who it is
i don't want to know but
i think it's interesting to think
through like everyone does assume
um the other thing that i learned
recently is there's only one time ever
satoshi
revealed gender uh he was signing
up for something i use him because uh
when he signed up i forget what it was
uh it asked for her birthday and it
asked for gender
and selected mail now could have been
thrown
right so you don't know right but like
that's the only time ever that
there was gender involved in a way that
uh satoshi
you know kind of um said anything about
their what was the birthday
uh i forget exact birthday but i put
them in there like i think mid to late
40s
2010 so like mid to late 50s today
interesting all right so like
it could be could be who knows i don't
think i want to know no no i definitely
don't want to know yeah uh
there's an element of um if you don't
know nobody can say
uh oh that's far right or far left or
that's a man that's a woman that's a
white person a black person a green
person that's a
american uh you know somebody from
another country uh oh that's a christian
that's a muslim right that's
right it's just nothing so entire
conversation
like knowing that it the protocol yeah i
think that it's just
it's not bad if people knew all it does
is it just removes
one other thing that people can say
right there's plenty of people who are
like oh i don't like vitalik
right i don't think vitalik's done
anything that's like
worth attacking or being mad at him or
not liking him or anything like that but
it's just like
because they know who vitalik is he
tweets something
everyone freaks out right half the
people are like yes he's you know
he's the king right right people are
like he's an idiot right right right
like whatever so like that just adds
another level of complexity so it's not
so much like you solve a problem
as much as uh or that it necessarily
matters as much as just
it's one less thing for people to attack
and so if everyone's yelling screaming
about
bitcoin and oh by the way the creator of
the protocol does something
it just is another kind of attack vector
right um
when you think about uh the last year of
your life
what are the two things that you're like
i cannot believe
this happened like maybe one positive
surprise and one negative surprise
um i would say they're probably both
related to
my experience on the bachelor and i
would say that the first
positive is he's talking about it like
my experience with the bachelor like it
was like uh
i don't know how to like yeah i got you
i don't know how to refer to it because
it's like
like it's like the process or like the
experience and like i don't like saying
it's a show
and then like i'm like saying
contestants because then it like takes
away like the
clinical yeah it doesn't feel like it
was real it's like oh i was on like
when i think of show i think of like
freaking nickelodeon like
getting slimed like i don't think of
like you know what i mean like
i don't want that comparison to ever be
drawn with a relationship jeopardy stand
right up right
exactly so the price is right right yeah
you watch that all the time as a kid
exactly so yeah so the process um
going through that for me is like i
can't believe that i was able to
you know i went into it with an open
mind and i i'm i'm
shocked that i was able to find someone
like rachel that like
can put up with me has the type of heart
that she does and was able to
form that connection as a skeptic before
the show that you could find someone
like that on a tv show
and so like that was incredible and that
was a great takeaway from the whole
experience for me and then the second
thing would be
um just where we're at as a country and
um
the type of um things
that we need to do and grow uh in
having the conversations that we need to
be had not only around race but
diversity inclusion
uh you would think that we would be
further along
um but it gives me hope that we're
having those conversations now so those
are two things that
um i never would have thought would be
yeah the
byproduct of this experience for me all
right before we get into rapid fire
questions to answer rachel
do you know how lucky you are to have
this guy this guy is amazing
i just want it to be known right now
that i said that
so it's on record you are so lucky to
have this guy all right so we keep going
so listen
just give me twenty dollars
what what is the most important book
you've ever read oh man
the most important book hands down is
the bible i read the bible
uh i try to read it every day but that's
like kind of what grounds that's what
grounds me so
okay uh second comes from our friends
that ate sleep uh
i used to sleep like five six hours i
was real bad right uh my lovely wife
said hey sleep is important i mean
because she didn't want me to keep
waking her up and all this stuff i see
rachel pumping her arms over here all
right
so i gotta eat sleep now right and i
like this thing so much that i
invested in the company because it's a
bed that they make super cold on
uh you can make it cold or hot shut up i
make it freezing cold
i sleep like a baby eight nine hours
it's amazing uh
and it's got sensors in it that can tell
you you know
uh how deep was your sleeve how many
times did you toss and turn whatever
like it tracks all stuff
only downside is when you first get it
out of the box it's a fun tip for
everybody
it also has like a vibration alarm in it
so it asks you when you're setting up
the app it's like you know what time you
wanna wake up
at eight o'clock first night go to sleep
in it that thing woke up
i swear i thought it was an earthquake
listen what the [ __ ] is that
that's the only downside but i love this
thing what is your sleep schedule and
based on
rachel's reaction it must not be very
good bro i could tell you
without a shadow of a doubt if you had
asked what rachel's biggest
problem with our relationship right now
is is my sleep cycle
all right how many hours do you sleep so
i
typically sleep five hours like okay
like six
max but like which i used to think was
normal
right so like and and and i and to get
to that point like
i don't like to wake like if i had to
wake up at 5am i'm not going to set an
alarm for 5 am i'm going to set alarm
for 2 am
because when my alarm goes off at 2 i'm
like oh thank god i have 3 hours left
and then i'm going to set alarm for 2 15
because i'm going to look at it at 15
minutes i'm like oh i have
2 hours and 45 minutes left so i set
like 10 alarms
and whole time i'm rachel i'm i'm more
probably 20 and i'm waking up
because i hit snooze so rachel's just
like having to deal with this
but when i'm with rachel she um
she likes to sleep she likes the room to
be like a bomb shelter
like the the the curtains have to be all
the way down there can't be any light
coming into the room
the the phone faces are down so like i
could wake up
if i if mile and she'll she'll she
turned my alarms off she had me set one
alarm
and so when that goes off i'm obviously
not gonna get on i'm not gonna get up
off that
so i wake up i went to bed at 11 p.m
it's three in the afternoon because i
didn't have an alarm
like there's no concept of time it's
completely dark and i look at the phone
and i'm breathing hard i'm like yo it's
i've been asleep for 11 hours
she's torturing you yeah she is
[Laughter]
i love is that she doesn't have a
microphone so she can't say anything
all right so what so you still only
sleep five six hours or she's got you
well it depends so like
like when i monday through friday like i
try to get like five or six hours but on
the weekends like
sleeping i'll sleep in a little bit all
right last question and you get asked me
one to finish is
aliens are you a believer or
non-believer bro i am
i am a believer i think that there's
because um
i think that there's well
a bunch of reasons but i think that
there's too much smoke to not be fire
like
like like i don't know necessarily what
they look like like if they look like
e.t or if they look like a transformer
but like there's too much going on for
there not to be some sort of like
did you see the cephalopod test i didn't
see that
oh man i haven't talked about this on
podcasts in a long time so
cephalopod i don't even know if you
showed me 10 things i couldn't tell you
what a cephalopod looks like but it's
something in the ocean
and they gave it an intelligence test
designed for like four-year-olds or
something and it passed
you're lying i swear and i by the way i
don't know what's in the intelligence
test i don't want to know
uh i don't know how you administer an
intelligence test to a fish
or whatever i don't want to know that
either but all i know is that i've read
multiple reports that it passed the
intelligence test
okay and so uh when i think of alien i
always think of like out in space right
but there is [ __ ] in the ocean that
scares the house hey me too
rachel's afraid of sharks sharks yeah
do you think sharks or octopus are
scarier like the octopus
feels like you can [ __ ] you up pretty
bad so so you know what you know what
that's actually hilarious you say that
because
what's that documentary there's a
documentary called my octopus teacher
and like and and now like we can't you
octopus if you octopus and you're
cancelled uh
so i i have to watch the documentary i
might feel the same way so i can't even
speak to you yeah yeah
but like apparently uh you yeah you
can't teach her you got to watch it all
right
can you eat sharks though if we don't
like them yeah sharks are endangered
yeah they're sharks either oh have you
ever seen the uh the viral video
of the woman uh who's in her car and i
don't know if she's driving or just
sitting there
and she's like i've been telling y'all
y'all want to go to the beach no problem
go to the beach but don't go in the
shark's house cause if the shark comes
in my house i'm eating it so if you go
in the shark's house shark's gonna eat
you
wow it's like a two-minute video this
[ __ ] is
hysterical that's a great way to think
about it yeah don't go in the shark's
house respect the sea
you know what's crazy when i was in
jupiter there was
a uh i was living in jupiter quarantine
there was the biggest tiger shark i've
ever seen in my entire life
on video uh there's this guy he's just
paddle boarding
maybe 50 feet off shore
maybe 50 60 feet off shore this dude's
paddle boarding and he and he puts his
gopro under the water
i prom i i don't maybe what did he do
15 20 foot long tiger shark that has a
whole hammerhead shark in his mouth
ripping it up and this is underneath his
paddle board bro
like he's just paddle boarding there's
people playing on the beach and like
yo i'm gonna send you the video video
it's crazy yeah i don't i don't go in
the shark's house
i get why people would be yeah i'm good
i like to look at it it's nice you know
go there's a breeze but
going inside i'm good yeah just go to
the pool all right what question you
have for me to finish up
um if you could tell yourself your 20
year old self
one thing looking back on your whole
life experience what would you tell
yourself two things
no [ __ ] fear and go bigger everything
that you do in life
uh takes the same amount of effort
regardless of the output
right like if you wanna accomplish
something you have to work hard at it
right
but if you work hard at accomplishing a
small thing then you get a small reward
but you work hard at accomplishing a big
thing you get the big reward
so it's kind of like you know think of
like sports right
you have to play just as hard in the
first game of the season as the
championship game
right if you want to win right but
obviously the championship game is way
more important
right right from just a pure like the
payoff of it right so
if you want to actually accomplish
things in the world you're going to do
the work anyways like go after big
things right because the asymmetry is so
much better
and i think just like when you're
younger it's almost like uh uh in
baseball like batting average like like
you want to hit about a thousand right
every time i do some i want to be
successful
right but as you get older i think you
realize like slugging percentage is more
important
right i'll need to get a hit every time
when i get a hit it's a home run right
right
i like that and so like that's a
framework that i think it's just it's
really really hard when you're younger
and then as you get older and you
realize that you're like damn i've been
doing it wrong the whole time right like
you look at all these super successful
people
right like uh take masayoshi's son from
softbank right
he's been the richest person in the
world twice right he ain't the richest
person anymore
right and one time he literally was a
richest person in the world and lost 99
of his wealth and then came back right
like how do you do that like you just
you always take big swings right right
and so like yeah cool he
probably didn't enjoy the 99 right right
which is he was taking big swings right
mike novogratz from uh galaxy digital
i think he he's gonna kill him if i get
this wrong uh i think he's been a
billionaire
three different times billionaire not a
billionaire billionaire not a
billionaire billionaire now again yeah
and he's now
i think wealthier than he's ever been
and so it's just like
you just see enough of the data points
you're like all right just go big yeah
all right where can we send people to
find on the internet oh man uh abc
food tours that's uh our non-profit that
we work with the students
uh and we've got our sustainability uh
model going
and then abcfoodtours.com
abcfoodtours.org
on any social and then me personally
matt james 919. all right and then uh
obviously if we go to rachel's uh
spotify playlist we'll see you there
yeah anything on rachel's socials as
well because i'm going to be scouring it
especially the social uh spotify because
she has better music than i do so
all right thank you for doing this
absolutely appreciate you bro